>>Teacher: What are some of
the ways that we can use money?
>>Student: Spending,
investing, sharing and saving.
>>Elaine: The kids are saving
money and they're setting goals.
What do I want to save my money for?
And some of the children are
actually starting to save
for college, which is just incredible.
>>Krupa: Come on in, hi.
Good morning, how are you?
Your saving to go to college?
It's so good that you're
saving for it now.
>>Anthony: If you teach financial
literacy without application,
or you offer a bank account
without the financial literacy,
it doesn't really work.
So Bracken has actually combined both,
and is teaching financial literacy
in the classrooms, sending homework
and curriculum home that actually works
with parents, and then every Friday,
there's a live bank that goes on here.
>>Krupa: We come on campus early
in the morning and we're on campus,
and we set up a small bank on
campus, in a little janitor's closet.
>>Teacher: You have fourteen
twenty-five,
so you're almost there, okay?
>>Krupa: They are given a deposit
bag at the beginning of the year.
The bag includes a deposit book and
deposit slips, and that's to allow them
to track and record their
weekly deposits.
>>Student: If I deposit the first
time, I would have got to the stamp.
>>Teacher: Yeah, it's okay.
You just keep depositing,
even if it's just fifty cents
or a quarter or a penny that you find.
As long as you deposit every
Friday, you'll still make it, okay?
>>Elaine: The kids can bring in as
little as a quarter and deposit it
in their account every Friday.
>>Katie: We always tell them, you can
at least find a penny or ask to do a job
or see if you can earn some money
that you can put in your bank.
>>Peyton: I am saving
for a car or a computer.
>>Elizabeth: I want to use
my money, is by saving it,
and so later on when I retire
and stuff, I have a lot of money.
>>Krupa: We stamp them, we help
them track their participation
and then we reward them with a sticker.
>>Lance: It gets the kids
used to saving money.
It gets them looking forward to a goal.
You're not allowed to take the money out
until you graduate from Walter Bracken.
So they actually get to
watch that money grow,
even if it's only a few cents a week
or a dollar here, a dollar there.
>>Krupa: Participation,
yeah, super saver.
>>Teacher: So remember, when we're
thinking about needs and wants,
we have to think about who we are,
because everybody is different
and everyone has different needs.
Something that I might
need, you might not need.
>>Elizabeth: It's like, preparing me.
Like, each time she comes in, I
learn something new about saving
and spending and investing and sharing.
>>Ethan: They're teaching life lessons,
like how you should know how to save
and spend, because when we become an
adult and if we're never taught this,
then we're not going to know what to do.
>>Teacher: Yes, you get
interest, and what is interest?
>>Student: Interest is when the bank
gives you more money for spending.
>>Elaine: So in the third grade,
they focus a lot on wants and needs.
What do I want and what do I
really need to take care of myself?
>>Teacher: We're going to pass
out the cards and when I say go,
you and your table together
pick six things to try
and help you survive on
the island, all right?
>>Student: No, no, wait, a saw, yes,
to chop down trees to get firewood.
>>Teacher: So what did
your group choose?
>>Students: Clean water, dried food,
matches, medicine, seeds and blankets.
>>Teacher: Really, really good choices.
I think you would survive.
Awesome, you all made
amazing choices today.
>>Teacher: How much money do
you think you have in total?
>>Katie: I want my students
not to have a ton of debt.
I want them to know to have a savings
account in case of an emergency.
I want them to plan for their
retirement and not get caught off guard,
and so that they can
actually live a comfortable,
financially secure life in the future.